et on va parler aussi d'un projet
insolite tout de suite qui pourrait
peut-être intégrer vos informations
insolites qui mêlent théâtre et aussi
magie pour aborder les mécanismes de la
manipulation le spectacle Cérébro sera
proposé ce samedi 15 avril du côté du
scarabée à La Verrière l'horaire 20h30 à
la baguette Mathieu villatel de la
compagnie du Pharo qui est avec nous par
visio-conférence bonsoir
bonsoir vous nous entendez bien alors
Cérébro vous l'avez coécrit avec Kurt
deux mec qui signe également la mise en
scène et c'est un spectacle qui est
avant tout une avant tout une
sensibilisation ludique aux techniques
de manipulation pourquoi c'est un sujet
que vous avez voulu traiter
parce que le mentalisme en fait c'est un
art du mensonge c'est le même outil que
le magicien on fait croire de des choses
fausses et donc on pose la question du
vrai et du faux et aussi ça pose des
questions de rapport de pouvoir et donc
je trouvais que c'était un outil
intéressant pour parler de la
manipulation la croyance c'est une
question centrale dans votre travail
c'est quoi votre constat les gens sont
enclin facilement à faire confiance aux
autres finalement le cerveau est
facilement malléable
je crois que les spécialistes des biais
cognitives vous savez les failles de
notre cerveau disent que même lorsqu'ils
sont formés qui connaissent très très
bien les biais ils continuent à tomber
dedans que c'est très très difficile en
fait de se préparer ou de se prémunir
face à la manipulation
et alors dans cérébraux vous êtes miguru
mis coach de vie d'ailleurs le spectacle
est en fait un faux programme de
développement personnel qui va permettre
au spectateur de révéler leur véritable
potentiel ce genre de programme de
technique on a quand même l'impression
ces dernières années que ça pullule des
livres sur le développement personnel
des spectacles sur le développement
personnel on en a vu des milliers alors
des milliers peut-être pas mais des
dizaines ces dernières années
c'est ça oui c'est ça que je trouvais
aussi très intéressant c'est que
maintenant c'est assez facile de devenir
coach en développement personnel on
envoie en effet de plus en plus
notamment sur les sur les plateformes et
c'est pas forcément des gens qui ont
une formation très très poussée et en
fait très rapidement on peut on peut
monter un institut de coaching donc
c'est ce qu'on fait là au théâtre
alors le but c'est de montrer
non non allez-y le mentalisme oui ça
permet de monter
ça permet de très vite faire croire
qu'on a des capacités développées et des
capacités un peu surhumaines
et alors le but c'est de montrer tout le
processus d'embrigadement ça se fait
étape par étape je crois que c'est ce
que vous appelez le l'escalier de la de
la croyance c'est ça
ouais tout à fait l'idée c'est de voir
comment on peut petit à petit accorder
la confiance et comme c'est difficile
une fois que la confiance est en place
de revenir de dessus mais ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de parler de la
manipulation mais de l'endroit où en
fait on se on se retrouve à aller là où
on n'a pas forcément envie d'aller au
départ
alors le tout je le disais de manière
ludique parce que vous avez vous allez
utiliser la magie au cours de ce
spectacle comment vous l'utilisez
justement
la magie on le spectacle elle est à la
fois partout et en même temps un peu
nulle part c'est à dire que c'est que
des expériences de magie mais c'est
beaucoup des c'est très interactif donc
c'est beaucoup des personnes du public
qui la pratiquent et qui montrent qu'en
fait très vite je peux les former qui
peuvent avoir des capacités
particulières et on l'a écrit pour
qu'elle soit à la fois forte mais en
même temps assez crédible aussi pour
qu'on puisse se dire ah non en fait
peut-être que c'est vrai peut-être qu'on
peut apprendre à faire ce genre de
choses
alors comment vous l'avez préparé ce
spectacle vous êtes beaucoup intéressé
notamment à la Scientologie les
mécanismes de la scientologie
oui bah forcément ça m'a intéressé alors
pas que la Scientologie mais en effet
pas mal de mouvements sectaires parce
que la secte c'est un peu poussiéreux
mais je crois que par contre la
manipulation sectaire elle est encore
très présente et notamment sur les sur
les réseaux sociaux et on la voit de
plus en plus et donc ce qui
m'intéressait c'est quels sont les
processus qui sont mis en place pour
voilà nous nous amener à plonger en
quelque sorte et donc ça veut dire que
quand on va venir voir ce spectacle le
spectateur justement va sortir de là en
ayant un quelques clés pour être un peu
plus vigilant à l'avenir c'est ça aussi
ça le but
oui alors en même temps je crois pas que
le spectacle soit qu'il est une morale
souvent en tant qu'artiste on vient
partager des questionnements qu'on se
pose sur le monde avec les spectateurs
et moi je viens donner mon point de vue
sur la manipulation mon point de vue de
mentaliste mais je crois qu'on repart
avec plus de questions peut-être que
qu'avec de réponse c'est un spectacle
que vous jouez depuis longtemps
ça va être la cinquième saison et là
vous vous êtes actuellement dans un
théâtre pour jouer le spectacle ce soir
peut-être
oui je suis à la lanterne à Rambouillet
d'accord oui donc un spectacle qui tombe
dans les Yvelines Rambouillet c'est
aujourd'hui c'est ce soir et donc il
sera joué du côté de la verrière samedi
15 avril je rappelle juste un l'horaire
c'est 20h30 et on peut avoir toutes les
informations et aussi on peut réserver
son billet sur le site
kiosque.sqy.fr merci Mathieu il attelle
d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous pour ce spectacle donc
Cérébro qui sera juste je le rappelle ce
samedi du côté de la verrière